and a new controversy involving the
Secret Service and the January 6th
attack the agency is on the defensive
this morning over allegations it deleted
text messages from before and during the
Insurrection and here's the key part
after investigators requested those text
messages Nicole Killian is on Capitol
Hill for us once again Nicole good
morning what more do we know about these
texts well Tony the Secret Service
denies it maliciously deleted text
messages after an agency Watchdog
requested them and says it is fully
cooperating this follows a letter
obtained by CBS news from the Department
of Homeland Security Inspector General
to a pair of congressional committees it
states that many U.S Secret Service text
messages from January 5th and 6 2021
were erased the Secret Service says
before an investigation was launched it
reset its phones as part of a system
migration that resulted in some data
being lost and agency official adds it
has turned over more than 786
and emails and 7 000 text chats related
to January 6. the select committee met
last night but declined to comment on
the matter one member said the panel is
working through a number of issues
including whether to hear from the
former president and vice president
another hearing is scheduled next week
Vlad
all right Nicole thank you very much